[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تصاعدت المواجهات بين القوات
المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه حفطر وقوات
رئاسه الاركان المنبثقه عن المؤتمر الوطني
العام تصاعد ترافق مع دعوه للحوار بين
الاطراف الليبيه برعايه الامم المتحده كان
يفترض ان يعقد في الخامس من يناير نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ماذا وراء هذا التصعيد ومن
المستفيد
منه ما هي افاق الحوار بين الاطراف
الليبيه في ظل هذا التصعيد وما هو موقف
الامم المتحده وخطوت
اللاحقه عشرات القتلى والجرحى يسقطون في
ليبيا كل يوم جراء المواجهات بين القوات
المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه حفطر من
جهه وقوات رئاسه الاركان المنبثقه عن
المؤتمر الوطني العام من جهه اخرى خاصه في
منطقه الهلال النفطي قتال دع الامم
المتحده الى التدخل واقتراح عقد حوار جديد
بين الاطراف الليبيه ومع دعوه الحوار
تتصاعد حده المواجهه مما يلقي بضلال على
افاقه
الله اكبر لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت الحرب
الطاحنه في ليبيا حتى عشيه موعد مضروب
امميا لجلسه حوار بين
الفرقاء قتلى وجرحى بالعشرات سقطوا قبيل
الحوار المفترض في اشتباكات مسلحه بمحيط
ميناء السدره النفطي شرق العاصمه الليبيه
طرابلس بين القوات المواليه للمؤتمر
الوطني العام وقوات حرس المنشات النفطيه
المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
القتال الدائر حول مناطق الهلال النفطي لا
يعصف بفرص الحوار فقط بل يتسبب ايضا في
تراجع الانتاج النفطي الليبي الى نحو 250
ال برميل مقابل 800 ال برميل قبل الازمه
في اجواء مماثله اسفرت معارك متزامنه
ببنغازي شرقي البلاد عن مقتل سته من قوات
اللواء المتقاعد حفتر وفي ذات السياق
التصعيدي تبنت قوات حفتر السبت القصف
الجويه على ميناء مصرات البحري غربي
البلاد بدعوى استخدامه فيما اعتبرته
اغراضا ارهابيه ماك كان كما يبدو حتى
الساعه لحوار سياسي تحاول البعثه الامميه
دفعه دون جدوى منذ ان حدد مبعوث المنظمه
الدوليه الى ليبيا برناردينو ليون الخامس
من يناير موعدا للاجتماع بين اطراف النزاع
الليبي عقب حصوله منهم على موافقه بشان
خارطه طريق تتضمن تشكيل حكومه وحده وطنيه
ووقف اطلاق النار وانسحاب المقاتلين ووضع
دستور جديد غير ان الساعات الاخيره شهدت
تصعيدا اجرائيا رافق التصعيد العسكري حيث
قرر رئيس مجلس النواب المنحل في طبرق
اعاده اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر للخدمه
العسكريه الى جانب اكثر من 120 ضابطا منهم
صقر الجروشي قائد سلاح الجو فيما تعرف
بعمليه الكرامه يقول مراقبون ان الخطوه
بمثابه اعداد لحفتر للمشاركه في الحوار
حال
انعقاده حوار لا يزيد احتدام القتال فرصه
الا تضاؤل حتى نقل في وقت سابق عن بعض
اعضاء المؤتمر الوطني العام مطال
بوقف الحوار الوطني الذي ترعاه الامم
المتحده ردا على الغارات التي تنفذها
طائرات حفتر على مواقع مدنيه ومنشات حيويه
مختلفه وضع يزداد
تازمامارت
الان اصوات الحوار لصالح اله الحرب
الداميه موضوع قتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
طرابلس الباحث السياسي وليد رتيمه ومن
تونس محمود المصراتي رئيس تحرير صحيفه
اخبار الحدث ومن نيويورك عبد الحميد صيام
المتحدث السابق باسم الامم المتحده اهلا
بضيوفي الكرام سيدي عبد الحميد نتكلم عن
حوار ترعاه الامم المتحده ويتابعه بشكل
دقيق مبعوثها الى ليبيا ومع ذلك تفشل حتى
الان في جمع اطراف النزاع الى طاوله
الحوار ما السبب
نعم السبب ان هناك اطرافا في ليبيا تحاول
حسم المعركه بالطرق المسلحه اي
بالسلاح هناك محاولات من مبعوث الامم
المتحده وقد قامت الاطراف بتسليمه اسماء
المندوبين في مؤتمر الحوار لكن على الارض
هناك ممارسات اخرى التصعيد الذي مر في
اليومين او الثلاثه الماضيين كان اكبر من
اي وقت وقت مضى اي كان هناك استهداف لقوات
في سبها اقصى الجنوب وكان هناك غارات على
مصراته وكان هناك استهداف لبنغازي وكذلك
سر تم خطف 20 مصريا من الديانه القبطيه
المسيحيه وبالتالي هناك فئات تحاول ان
تصعد كيف يمكن ان يتم مؤتمر حوار يجمع
جميع الاطراف والكل يمسك السلاح ويحاول
ان يفني الاخر بالطرق المس
ملف ليبيا سيدي عبد الحميد ملف ليبيا
موجود على مستوى مجلس الامن وعلى مستوى
البند السابع لما لم تفعل الامم المتحده
ما لديها من اليات من اجل اولا تحميل
المسؤوليه للطرف الذي يعرقل اي حوار
وبالتالي اتخاذ
اجراءات نعم هناك القرار الذي اتخذته
الامم المتحده بتاريخ 29 اب اغسطس الماضي
24 7 لتصعيد عمليه
مراقبه التسلح
وا الاختراقات الامنيه وتصنيف كل الجماعات
التي تنتهك سياده وامن ليبيا وهذه اللجنه
تتابع عملها لكن على الجانب الاخر هناك
محاولات تهدئه محاولات بناء جسور بين
الاطراف لان الذي يدعو الى الحوار يحاول
ان يغض الطرف مؤقتا على الاقل عن بعض
الانتهاكات للوصول الى مائده الحوار هناك
مشروع تقدم به السيد برناردينو على اساس
ان يلتقي الجميع ويبدا من نقطه الصفر
بتشكيل حكومه مؤقته تعمل على نزع السلاح
وتعمل على اعاده جميع المليشات الى الى
المرابض ثم يبدا تبدا عمليه تحديد مواعيد
للانتخابات والى اخره لكن هذا لم يتم
تحاول الامم المتحده طريق السلم الطريق
السلمي لكنه يبدو انه الان وصل الى طريق
المسدود حيث تم تاجيل مؤتمر الحوار مرتين
في في التاسع من ديسمبر كانون الاول
الماضي وفي الخامس من الذي كان م عن هذا
الطريق المدو سجله بدون تحديد موعد اخر
اسال ضيفي من طرابلس ومن تونس نفس السؤال
لكل من ضيفي السيد وليد رتيمه وكذلك محمود
المصراتي من المستفيد من تاجيل الحوار مره
بعد مره وربما الغائه ووصوله الى الطريق
المسدود كما يقول ضيفي من نيويورك ابدا
بالسيد
وليد السلام عليكم في البدايه احييك واحيي
كل مشاهدين قناه الجزيره اعتقد قبل
الاجابه على سؤالك علينا ان ان نحاول ضبط
المصطلح اكثر نحن الان في المشهد الليبي
لا ارى معنى لكلمه حوار او لا توجد كلمه
حوار من الناحيه العلميه او من الناحيه
الضمنيه نحن امام حاله تفاوض بين طرفين
سياسيين كل طرف لديه ذراع عسكري وذراع
اعلامي نحن نحن امام حاله تفاوض بين قوتين
غير متجانستين
اصلا وهنا تكمن صعوبه مهمه الوسيط انا هنا
اسمي السيد بردين ليونا وصفه في هذه في
هذه المرحله بالوسيط الذي يحاول تجميع
اطراف التفاوض على على على طاوله واحده
عندك في في طرابلس عندك التشكيلات المسلحه
او التوار الموجودين على الارض لا نستطيع
ان نقول ان الحكومه حكومه الانقاد
المنبثقه على المؤتمر تتحكم بشكل الكامل
في هذه القوات لا نستطيع ايضا ان نقول بان
المؤتمر الوطني يمثل ظهيرا سياسيا لهذه
القوه على الارض بالمعنى الحقيقي للكلمه
ايضا في في الشرق لا نستطيع ان ان ان نفك
الارتباط او نفهم من يسيطر على من هل حفتر
يسيطر على البرلمان ام البرلمان يسيطر على
حفتر ايضا لا نستطيع ان ان ان ان ان نفهم
هذه القوه الغير متجانسه داخل البرلمان
انت عندك تيار فيدرالي وعندك قوه التحالف
الوطني وايضا هناك ا ا القوه خلينا نقولوا
المعتدله واللي تتمثل في السيد شعيب اللي
هو يعتبر رئيس الفريق المحاور من من من
طبرق انت امام حاله متشرد صعبه جدا
صعبه مختلفه الافكار مختلفه الاهداف دون
في نفس الوقت لدينا وسيط لن يحدد اهداف
هذا هذا الحوار او هذا التفاوض لن يحدد
اليات لن لن يحدد بعد رؤيه واستراتيجيه
واضحه باستثناء هدف واحد الذي وضح للجميع
الان وهو انتاج حكومه وحده وطنيه تنهي
حاله الانقسام على المستوى التنفيذي
فبذلك لكي يكون من مقدور هذه الحكومه ان
تسعى لوقف اطلاق النار ا عد تحديد هدف
واضح من قبل المبعوث الدولي وعدم الوضوح
في المسميات فيما يتعلق بطبيعه التشكيلات
في داخل ليبيا تراها سبب في عدم الوصول
الى هذا الهدف المنشود وهو الحوار وهنا
انتقل لسؤالي لضيف في تونس السيد محمود
عوائق اليه وعوائق نعم نفس السؤال من
المستفيد كل مره من عمليه التاجيل والوصول
الى هذه الحاله المسدوده فيما يتعلق
بالوصول الى طاوله يجلس حولها
الليبيون في اعتقادي عبد القادر المستفيد
هو الجماعات الارهابيه التي اصبحت تنمو
بشكل متزايد في ليبيا واصبحت تشكل بعرا
ارهابيه حقيقيه واصبحت الان تقود عمليات
مسلحه ضد المدنيين وضد القوات المسلحه وضد
البوابات التي يتواجد فيها الجيش
ايضا هناك مساله مهمه جدا بعد ان جاوبتك
على سؤالك توصيف حقيقي التوصيف الحقيقي
للازمه الليبيه واللي انا حقيقه مشفق على
السيد برنين اليون هناك ضيفك السيد وليد
من طرابلس قال بان هناك قوتين سياسيتين
لديهم ادرع عسكريه موجدتان عن الارض
وبالتالي هاتان
القوتان في امام حاله من التفاوض على
العكس اطلاقا وهو فند ما قاله في البدايه
في نهايه حديثه السيد الصديق وليد
ما يوجد على الارض الطرف السياسي الاخر
المقابل لشرعيه الدوله والبرلمان الجيش
الوطني الذي يقاتل بما يعرف بميليشيات فجر
ليبيا يقاتل ميليشيات موجوده على الارض
الاطراف السياسيه التي يستهدفها السيد
اليون ليست لديها القدره الحقيقيه اطلاقا
على
زمام زمام الامور والسيطره على هذه
الميليشيات لن تستطيع ولا يعني وهذا اصبح
واضح حتى للسيد اليون تستطيع هذه الاطراف
السياسيه سواء من اعضاء نواب البرلمان
ال الممتنعين عن حضور جلسات البرلمان في
طبرق او حتى الاطراف السياسيه الاخرى
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين او الجماعه
الليبيه المقاتله بما يمثلها من تيار
تيارها السياسي وما يسمى كتله الوفاء داخل
ما يعرف بالمؤتمر الوطني العام السابق هذه
المجموعات السياسيه ليست لديها القدره
للسيطره على الاطراف التي تقاتل على الارض
على الميليشيات التي تقاتل على الارض
وبالتالي استاذ عبد القادر في اعتقادي ما
همت السيد اليون الان اصبحت من لن لن
استطيع ان اقول مستحيله ولكنها صعبه بمكان
ا لذا السيد اليون هو تفطر لهذه المساله
وتحدث عن طاوله اخرى بجانب الطاوله
السياسيه ل للميليشيات ومراء الحرب وهنا
كان اعتراض البرلمان حقيقه اما الان
التوصيف الحقيقي ميليشيات و والمجموعات
التي تسمى فجر ليبيا الان اصبح لديها خطر
اخر هناك تحالف استراتيجي بينها وبين
جماعه انصار الشريعه في في المنطقه الوسطى
تحالفت هي في السابق ما يعرف دروع الاخوان
الدرع الاول والثاني والثالث في بنغازي
تعرفوا تحالفوا مع انصار الشريعه في في في
بنغازي الان فجن المجودين في المطقه
الغربيه اصبحت زمام الامار الامار توصيفك
لسبب سبب لا فقط حتى اكون عادلا في توزيع
الوقت بين ضيوفي توصيفك لسبب عدم جلوس
لبين طاوله التفاوض ان هناك طرف يتحكم فيه
ميليشيات تصفها بخلفيات المتطرفه هي من
تعيق هذه المساله سؤالي للاستاذ عبد
الحميد س فيما يتعلق بما يسمعه ما يدور من
كلام بانه ربما قد يكون مصير المبعوث
الدولي سيد بدينو هو نفس مصير المبعوث
السابق السيد طارق متري وهو الاستقاله او
تنحي جانبا عن اداء الملف الليبي باعتباره
وصل الى حاله من الانسداد هل استمعت في
اروقه الامم المتحده الى كلام من هذا
القبيل لحد الان لم اسمع مثل هذا الكلام
صحيح تم تاجيل لقاء كان مقررا ان يلتقي
السيد برناردينو باعضاء مجلس الامن تم
تاجيله لانه كان مشغولا بترتيب جلسه حوار
ثانيه في الخامس من يناير كانون الثاني
الحالي لكنه طبعا لم يستطع بذلك كان يلتقي
بكافه الاطراف انا انتقادي لعمليه العمليه
التي يقودها السيد برناردينو انه يحصر
لقاءاته ب الاطراف الليبيه الازمه الليبيه
لم تعد فقط ازمه ليبيه انها انتاج اخر
للازمه السوريه وكما كان الابراهيمي يحاول
ان يلتقي بالاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه
المؤثره على الساحه السوريه برناردينو ما
زال منضبطا لداخل الساحه الليبيه من
المعروف ان الحوار الان بين طرفين اساسيين
في ليبيا هو حوار بالسلاح حتى لو سموا
مندوبيهم الى مؤتمر الحوار حتى لو التقوا
بالسيد برناردينو السيد برناردينو طبعا
منضبط لقرارات مجلس الامن قرارات مجلس
الامن تنص على ان فقط انصار الشريعه هي
حركه ارهابيه لا يستطيع ان يصنف اي تنظيم
اخر لم يصنفه مجلس الامن بانه ارهابي لكن
الحقيقه ان الاطراف الليبيه تتلقى مساعدات
وتدريبات واسلحه ودعم من خارج ليبيا
واصبحت الحرب الليبيه هي حروب بالوكاله
بين اطراف خارج ليبيا وبالتالي على الامم
المتحده وعلى السيد برناردينو اذا كان
يريد للحوار ان ينجح ان يوسع اتصالاته وان
يدعو كافه الاطراف ويصل الى رؤيه ليست فقط
تختص بليبيا بل بالمنطقه وايضا القوى
العالميه مثل فرنسا اخيرا والتي تدعو الى
تدخل في ل في الجزء الثان من هذه الحلقه
سوف نركز على مساله امكانيه حصول حوار في
ليبيا في ظل ما يجري عسكريا اعاده بعض
العسكريين مح على التقاعد الى الواجهه مره
اخرى بناء على قرارات معينه وهل لها علاقه
بحسابات تتعلق بالحوار ام ان ما يجري من
عزف على الارض يختلف تماما عن طبيعه
المعزوفه المنتظره من قبل الامم المتحده
بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش تصع المواجهات في ليبيا وافاق
الحوار بين الاطراف الليبيه مع هذا
التصاعد واجدد تحيه لضيوفي في هذه الحلقه
من تونس ومن طرابلس وكذلك من نيويورك سيد
ويدر تيما كيف تنظرون الى هذه الخطوه
باعاده بعض العسكريين الذين كانوا في حاله
تقاعد وعلى راسهم السيد خليفه حفتر الى
مناصبهم هل خطوه تتعلق بحسابات على الارض
ام لها علاقه بما يجري من حديث عن حوار او
مساعي او تكتيكات من هذا الطرف في مقابل
الطرف الاخر
في البدايه اريد ان انوه لنقطه فقط وهي
فكره تدعيش ليبيا واظهار ليبيا وانها
مليئه وتعج بالارهابيين في كل مكان وان
الحاله الليبيه اصبحت حاله وان الشعب
الليبي اصبح كله عباره عن عن عن عن
ارهابيين وعن ناس متطرفين وعن هذا لا يفيد
ولا يخدم الحاله الليبيه و وعلينا ان ان
ان نخفف من هذا الخطاب الاستئصالي الخطاب
الذي يلغي الاطراف الليبيه وعلينا ان نكون
اكثر واقعيه في تشريح الوضع الليبي
ومحاوله فهم الوضع الليبي بنظره واقعيه
تلامس الارض اكثر هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
ثانيه قرار ارجاع الضباط المتقاعدين اول
شيء هذا القرار يثبت ان ما كان يحصل
وماكان ما يعرف بالجيش الوطني هو عباره
عليه كان مجموعه مسلحه مقاتله ان صح
التعبير هي ميليشيا مثل غيرها من كل
الميليشيات التي تتقاتل في ليبيا هذه
النقطه الاولى لكن عمليه ارجاعهم انا في
اعتقاده هي مقدمه سياسيه لتاسيس مجلس
عسكري قد ياخذ قد يلعب الدور الكامل في
المرحله القادمه و ومحاوله لتحسين الدور
التفاوضي ل لبعض الضباط العسكريين الذين
خرجوا من الخدمه و وسموا انفسهم في
المرحله الاخيره بجيش وطني وقادوا حمله
الحقيقه دفعت بحتى من لا يرغب في القتال
الى القتال وحتى من لا يحمل فكر تطرف اصبح
متطرفا نتيجه هذه الحمله العسكر عسكريه
الهوجاء التي لم تميز احد انا في تقديري
ترجيعه الضباط هي خطوه لان نحن نعرف بان
هناك الان سوف يكون 10 ضباط من كل اقليم
في ليبيا يكونوا مجلس عسكري هذا المجلس
ينتخب رئيسا له في محاوله لاستنساخ
المشهد المصري ان صح التحبير بحيث يكون
هذا المجلس العسكري يتولى المهام بعض
المهام التنفيذيه ومهام اداره المرحله
القادمه ويبقى مجلس النواب عباره عن ظهير
سياسي مؤقت لهذا المجلس العسكري ا وايضا
في في نفس الوقت تحسين الوضع التفاوضي او
او محاوله ايجاد مكان على طاوله الحوار
لهذا الطرف العسكري وخاصه وان البرلمان
المنحل نفسه اثبت ان هذا الطرف او ان ان
هؤلاء الضباط هم كانوا يقودوا تشكيلات
عسكريه غير متجانسه قبليه تحمل افكار
مختلفه بواجهه سياسيه او بواج او بفكره
محاربه الارهاب لا اكثر يعني سيد محمود
المصراتي لو طلب من الليبيين ان يتنازلوا
حتى يوقفوا على الاقل حمام الدم الذي
يعاني منه المواطن الليبي بالدرجه
الاساسيه ما هو هامش التنازل المطلوب حتى
تقف جميع الاطراف وتتحاور بشكل جدي من اجل
ايجاد
مخرج التنازل بالدرجه الاولى يكون فكري
يكون بوجود قناعه الان هذا الحوار حتى مع
مع ضيفك الكريم السيد وليد يتحدث بان مثلا
تدعيش ليبيا ليبيا دعش وانتهى الامر
التفجيرات التي في في طرابلس الان ربما
تكون خلفه في مبنى الامن الدبلوماسي اعلنت
عليها داعش 15 15 جندي قتل قبل يومين في
بوابه سوخنا اعلنت داعش عنها مسؤوليتهم و
و وذاعت الصور قبلها في المحطه البخاريه
سرت قبلها الجنود عشرات الجنود مئات
الضباط ذبحوا على ارصفه بنغازي على يدين
التنظيمات الارهابيه في منطقه بنغازي هذه
ال ال هذه العمليات هي التي خلقت ما يعرف
بالكرامه وهي التي قادت اما قبل ان نجيبك
على سؤالك هناك ايضا نقطه مهمه جدا القرار
ان صدر عن عن عن البرلمان باعاده 129 ضابط
الى تقاعد ليس قرار سياسي هذه مساله
اداريه صرف هذا قرار اداري صرف لا علاقه
له لا علاقه لها اطلاقا باي مبادرات
سياسيه
باي باي محاوله الى خلق فرص للتفاوض لا
اعتقد البرلمان قادر على قياده التفاوض
البرلمان جهاز جسم تشريعي معترف به من كل
دول العالم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي و
وجامعه الدول العربيه وبالتالي هو لا
يحتاج الى الى الى الى ان يكسب اوراق اخرى
يفاوض بها هذه مساله مساله اخرى سيد سيدي
الفاضل يجب ان ننوه عنها ا الحوار الان
والتنازل يجب ان ان ان يكون مبني على
قواعد سليمه وقواعد اساسيه حتى ينجح فيها
هذا الحوار الاول اول هذه النقاط هو
الاعتراف بشرعيه الدوله وشرعيه البرلمان
النقطه الثانيه المحافظه على هذه البيضه
على هذه البوتقه وهو الوطن ليبيا يعني عدم
الاعتراف بوجود ارهاب ينخر في في في في
عظم الدوله الليبيه ينخر كما ينخر السوس
هذا في حد ذاته تجني على الواقع الليبي
اصلا يعني الان كل الذين يخرجون من طرابلس
الان ويتحدثون يقولوا لا يوجد ارهاب في
ليبيا وكل ما يطلع هو في اي واحد من النخب
في في طرابلس يخرج في الليل ثاني يوم ترد
داعش في اي منطقه من مناطق ليبيا واخرها
حتى سوكنه وقبلها طرابلس ويعلنوا ان داعش
موجوده وبالتالي هذه المفارقه الفكريه
ومساله صم الاذان واغلاق العينين على ما
يحدث في ليبيا لن يجعل من الحاله الليبيه
حاله قابله الى فرض تنازلات والى فرض مناخ
سياسي حقيقي ح المواق متمترس بهذا الشكل
وان سؤالي موجه للاستاذ عبد الحميد الصيام
فيما يتعلق بما يمكن ان تفعله الامم
المتحده هل الان مجلس الامن قادر على
اتخاذ اجراءات حتى لا ينزلق هذا البلد وكل
المؤشرات تقول بان ليبيا ماضيه في هذا
الاتجاه لا قدر الله هل يملك مجلس الامن
من الامكانيات ومن القرار ان يتدخل بشكل
رادع حتى يعيد الامور نصابها في
ليبيا طبعا بالتاكيد قادر على ذلك لان
المجلس يستطيع ان ياخذ قرارا تحت الفصل
السابع او يعيد تفعيل القرار 193 70 عام
2011 والذي فوض الامم المتحده بالتدخل من
اجل حمايه المدنيين اذا اعيد انتاج المشهد
لعام 2011 وهو ما يتم الان حاليا من
استهداف للمدنيين ما يزيد عن 600000 ليبي
اصبحوا مشردين هناك الاف القتلى هناك
استهداف لمناطق معينه هناك استهداف
للاجانب للمسيحيين خاصه هناك تفريخ لاكثر
من تنظيم في اكثر من موقع اذا وصلت الامم
المتحده ومجلس الامن وعاد برناردينو الى
مجلس الامن ليقدم تقريره الاخير ويقول هذا
هو الوضع في ليبيا اما ان ياخذ المجلس
قرارا للتدخل والا ليبيا منهاره بالتاكيد
وستتحول الى صومال ثانيه والى دوله فاشله
لوقع ان يحدق الم ان ياخذ قرارا تحت الفصل
السابع نعم هناك لجنه متابعه العقوبات على
ليبيا والمكونه من جميع اعضاء المجلس
الامن والتي تج تتمع دوريا وتراقب الوضع
ولديها تقارير بمن يقوم بماذا ومن ينتهك
ومن يستهدف المدنيين وتجمع كل هذه
المعلومات وهناك بيانات صادره ايضا عن
مجلس حقوق الانسان في جنيف عن عمليات
استهداف المدنيين وعن
انتهاكات ترقى الى مستوى جريمه حرب وجرائم
ضد الانسانيه ترتكب في ليبيا الوضع في
ليبيا لا يستحمل اذا اذا لم يعد مجلس
الامن قريبا لمناقشه الوضع واتخاذ قرارات
حاسمه في الموضوع واذا فشلت محاولات
الحوار التي يقوم بها السيد برناردينو
ليون اذا لا يوجد امام مجلس الامن الا
اتخاذ قرار جديد ل لعمليه التدخل في سيد
وليد ارتيمه في اقل من دقيقه ما هي حظوظ
ان ينجح المبعوث الدولي قريبا في اجلاس
الليبيه على طابه
الحوار في البدايه يجب ان ان ان ان نعترف
بان ليبيا فعلا تمر بمرحله صعبه والحوار
يجب ان يكون ليبي ليبي الحضوض
امام الوسيط او المبعوث الدولي متوقفه على
الاطراف الليبيه علينا ان نتوقف عن عن عن
عن عن عن التطرف الفكري علينا ان ان ان ان
ان نشاهد المشهد الليبي باكثر واقعيه
وباكثر فاعليه علينا ان نكون ايجابيين
اكثر علينا ان نبحث عن الحلول ولا نبحث عن
عن المشاكل واقصاء بعضنا البعض لن نصل
بهذه الطريقه الى اي حل يجب على الطبقه
السياسيه ان تكون مسؤوله جدا في هذه
المرحله الصعبه من تاريخ ليبيا عليها ان
تخفف من خطاب التحريضي عليها ان تتجه الى
بعضها وتفتح قنوات اتصال في اسرع وقت ممكن
لان البلد قاعد يمر بمرحله صعبه جدا فكره
الغر في اقل ايضا من 30 ثانيه كيف يمكن
مساعده المبعوث الدولي على ايجاد ارضيه
للحوار في
ليبيا تحديد الاطراف الحقيقيه التي
بامكانها الحوار وتجريم المجرمين
والاعتراف بان هناك ارهاب في ليبيا وبان
هناك جماعات ارهابيه حقيقيه سواء من اعلن
عن نفسها وتبعت وبايعت البغدادي في درناه
او هذه الخاليا التي بدات تعلن عن نفسها
سواء في الجنوب او في الغرب او في الشرق
او في المنطقه الوسطى وبالتالي باستثناء
هذه النقاط المهمه وهي الاعتراف بشرعيه
الدوله والالتفاف حول ليبيا الوطن اشكرك
سيد محمود المصراتي رئيس سحريه صحيفه
اخبار الحدث شكرا واعتذر ادركنا الوقت كما
اشكر ضيفي من طرابلس الباحث السياسي وليد
رتيبه وكذلك ضيفي من نيويورك السيد عبد
الحميد سيام المتحدث السابق باسم الامم
المتحده شكرا جزيلا لكم الى اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
الله